we've got some breaking news coming from
grant shaps the transport secretary
who has taken the urgent decision he
says to ban arrivals from
argentina brazil bolivia cape verde
chile colombia ecuador french guyana
guyana panama paraguay peru tsurinami
uruguay and venezuela and that comes
into force tomorrow
at 4 00 am travel from portugal also
suspended given its strong travel links
with brazil let's bring in our political
correspondent
rob powell at this was expected but
we didn't know which countries were
going to be involved it's a long list
rob
yeah i think potentially a bigger list
than was expected and i think the
crucial part of this announcement that
definitely wasn't expected
was the inclusion of portugal on that
list
as well grant chap saying because of
strong links between
portugal and brazil the travel ban
and the ban on arrivals will also be
extended to portugal he says that
that will be another way to reduce the
risk of importing infections
he says though there will be an
exemption for hauliers traveling
from portugal to allow the transport of
essential goods you can see the list
south american countries on your screen
they're coming into force tomorrow the
15th of jan um at 4 00 am
in terms of who this doesn't apply to it
doesn't apply to british and irish
nationals and third country nationals
with residents rights
but passengers returning from the
destinations who are british or irish
nationals or have residents here
they will need to self-isolate for 10
days along with their household so if
they're coming back
they will need self-isolate and the
people they live with will have to
self-isolate
um as well i think the inclusion of
portugal clearly trying to make sure
that people
can't get around the travel ban by
flying to a third country but
undoubtedly
that will cause quite a bit of
disruption rob powell
thanks very much so that travel ban uh
from
a number of countries they're coming
into force
at uh 4 am tomorrow